the function h is defined over the real
numbers this table gives a few values of
h so they give us for different x values
what is the value of h of x
what is a reasonable estimate for the
limit of h of x as x approaches one
so with the table we can estimate the
limit we won't know 100 for sure but
it's a good way to estimate a limit and
so what they're what they have here is
these first three entries show what's
happening as we approach x equals one
from the left from values less than x
equals one
and so we can see what is h of x for
those x values as we get closer and
closer to x equals one and we see let's
see when we're at 0.9 it's point it's
0.003 it's 3 thousandths
then when we get even closer to 1 then
the value of our function is negative 4
hundredths then when we get even closer
to 1 the value of h is 5 tenths
so this is so we have this oscillation
in sign
and it seems like the absolute value is
getting larger and larger
now if we approach from the right
if we approach x equals one from values
larger than one
so here's we're approaching from the
right
at one point one we're at three
thousandths at one point zero one we are
negative four hundredths at one point
zero zero one or one and one thousandth
we are at five tenths
so this is interesting it you know when
you have this oscillation of sine you
say well maybe we might be approaching
zero you know maybe something is getting
closer and closer and closer and closer
to
zero maybe something like that is
happening but what's troubling here the
reason why i would say that it's not
reason it's reasonable to think that the
limit doesn't exist is here as we're
getting closer and closer
here as we're getting closer and closer
we're getting fur the oscillations are
getting more and more significant so
actually think of it this way
as we're getting from the left
as we're getting closer and closer the
oscillations are getting more
significant and as we're going from the
right as we get closer and closer the
oscillations are getting
more
significant now it looks like there's a
little bit of symmetry here
let me see if i can
draw symmetry reasonably well
so it looks like something like this is
happening but this is implying this we
get you know as we go to
0.9999 then we're going to oscillate
again and we're going to get even
further away from zero and so we're
oscillating around zero but where the
oscillations are swinging wilder and
wilder so we're definitely not
approaching zero we're not getting
closer and closer the absolute value of
these aren't getting closer and closer
to zero so i would say that the limit
doesn't exist
so a takeaway here is
when things start to oscillate you're
probably already saying okay something
fishy is going on but that doesn't mean
that the limit doesn't always it doesn't
mean that the limit necessarily doesn't
exist just because of the oscillation
but if it's oscillating around a value
and as it's getting closer and closer
the oscillations are swinging wilder
further and further away from that value
then you have to worry and that then the
limit probably does not exist
let's do another example
the function h
is defined over the real numbers this
table gives a few values of h so
similar situation what is a reasonable
estimate for the limit as x approaches 3
of h of x so let's see as x approaches 3
from
the left
as x approaches 3 from the left
it looks like let's see 2.9 we're at 2
10 then at 2.99 we go to negative 2
hundredths then at two point nine nine
nine we get to positive two thousandths
so even though it's oscillating
magnitude wise we're getting closer and
closer to zero so this is an oscillation
that you know it might look like this
we're oscillating in sine but it looks
like we're getting closer and closer and
closer to
zero here
so this looks like we might be looks
like our function might be approaching
zero as x approaches three from the left
let's think about from the right
well from the right we see something
similar here 3.1 we're at negative 2 10.
3.01 positive 2 hundredths 3.001 or even
closer to 3 negative 2 thousandths
and so it looks like
we are definitely oscillating but the
oscillations are getting less and less
wild their their absolute value is
getting smaller and smaller so it
actually seems reasonable we're
oscillating around zero and with every
swing as we get closer and closer to x
equals three the oscillations are
getting smaller and smaller so once
again we don't know for sure we can't
prove it mathematically but from this
table it is reasonable to estimate that
the limit here
is zero
now these other choices are
i would call them distractors this one
down here is interesting because the
function is actually defined at x equals
three and it equals four but this might
be a situation where the limit is
approach we're getting closer and closer
but the function is defined up here at
four and this reinforces this idea that
look the limit can approach a value that
is different from the value that the
function is defined that's actually one
of the points of limits this is to study
what is a function approach even when
even when the function might be defined
at a different value or even when the
function isn't defined at that value
what is it approaching as x approaches
that value
now as i said you know
for this situation it's it's not it's
reasonable to think that the limit
exists i don't have any good information
to think otherwise we don't know 100
sure
they will put the 3 here
we're thinking about what is h
approaching as x approaches 3. now
there's no information here that would
imply that h is approaching 3 and this
is 0.22
they're just playing with the digits
right over here but this is getting
further from 0 than what seems like what
we're trying to approach so i'd rule
that one out as well but the big
takeaway here is
if you start to see us especially on a
table or anything that as you get closer
and closer to value that the function is
oscillating that should kind of put your
spider senses on notice but that doesn't
necessarily mean that the limit doesn't
exist
if the if the swings are getting wilder
and wilder as we approach the value that
we're oscillating around then the limit
probably doesn't exist but if the if the
swings the oscillations are getting
smaller in magnitude as we approach the
thing that we're oscillating around in
this case zero then it actually is
reasonable to think that the thing that
we're oscillating around actually is the
limit